travis barker's family is thankful for
the outpour of love his daughters are
speaking out after the blink 182 rocker
was hospitalized this is my support
group sixteen-year-old alabama barker
posted a new update showing her dad's
hand next to hers captioning the pic
thank you guys for all the prayers and
love i appreciate you and love all of
you travis's stepdaughter atiana who is
his ex shayna mukhler's daughter with
boxer oscar de la hoya also expressed
her gratitude for the well wishes
writing in her ig story it is heard felt
and appreciated
of course we now know that travis was
suffering from pancreatitis which is a
painful swelling of the pancreas gland
and our e.t sources share how it all
went down
according to our source travis was sick
and had intense pain in his abdomen
which really concerned him and wife
kourtney kardashian we're told the
couple wasted no time and immediately
jumped into action
another source says courtney drove him
to the hospital before being rushed by
ambulance to l.a cedar sinai hospital on
tuesday outside photos captured court in
all black sticking by her man's side as
paramedics wheeled travis on the
stretcher and his daughter alabama was
not too far away posting a pick holding
her dad's hand while hooked up to an iv
according to our et source doctors ran
several tests on travis before reaching
the diagnosis
but it's still unknown what exactly
caused the pancreatitis before the
medical emergency travis and courtney
were in preparation mode for expanding
their blended family and fresh off
newlywed bliss tying the knot in italy
we're just you know living our best
lives the couple's tough fertility
journey all played out on season one of
the kardashians
i'm super grateful that travis is doing
this with me i don't think i could do it
on my own i just feel like it's
something like we have to do together
we're making a baby together we have to
be on the same page
and kravis went to great lengths trying
to conceive their first child together
after a couple of failed attempts at ivf
treatment we did all these healthy
things and we made love and we made a
baby so now that we feel really healthy
we are going to
try naturally and take a big break from
ivf well whatever your journey around
courtney we support you we're all
supporting courtney and travis on their
parenting journey and hoping travis gets
better soon
[Music]
you